foreign
[Music]
we've arrived disruptors have assembled
[Music]
welcome gang we got a great weekend
our gratitude to be here when's the
murder mystery start
I've invited you all to My Island hi
because tonight a murderer will be
committed
my murder once you're dead will we still
be able to talk to you yeah I'm not
playing dead the whole weekend dude this
is truly delightful across the island
I've hidden Clues you will have to
closely observe each other if anyone can
name the killer that person wins our
game any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
for at least one person this is not a
game
I must insist that nobody touch the body
geez detective who killed the party
I need to find a motive for murder
everyone would stab a friend in the back
to hold on to this Rich bastard
you're all friends why would anyone
commit murder
are we even going to talk about the
elephant in the room
am I the elephant yeah you're the
elephant you're not that bad
let it all out hell yeah
the killer wouldn't hesitate to kill
again if it covers their tracks
you must be really great at clue huh I'm
very bad at dumb things ticking boxes
running around searching all the rooms
it's just a terrible terrible game
foreign
[Music]